behind the scenes with the man holding
surely one of the most demanding jobs in
government David Davis and of course the
team that surrounds him are responsible
not just for extricated us from the
European Union but fashioning our future
relationship still if the burden of
responsibility weighs heavily on his
broad shoulders
he gives precious little sign David
Davis clearly you are a very busy man
but this is the the sixth round of talks
were still not certain we're about to
move on to the negotiations about trade
do you understand why some people are
concerned about an apparent lack of
progress well I can see why people in
there just coming back to her from time
to time it actually has been a huge
amount of progress I mean the Commission
started off saying we want to do this
this way and we thought about arguing it
but actually we decided look there are
things in this which we need answers on
ourselves citizens rights being the
biggest one that one when we started
there was no knowledge what was going to
happen on citizens rights now we're
pretty clear how it's going to turn out
all the three million people in Britain
today the million Brits in Europe will
you know will have a protection of their
current lifestyle really that sort of
thing alone that alone let alone the
other three or four things we're dealing
with is a big achievement mmm but one of
the things that your appears this is a
sticking point is money it really is at
the heart of all of this isn't it and
you've got it appears to me two weeks to
come up with some more according to
Michele well yeah in every negotiation
the other side each side tries to
control the timetable the real the real
deadline on this of course is December
it's the December October Council which
you think about 14th December there
about but your readers your viewers are
all taxpayers I suspect one way or
another and they would not want me to
come along and just give away billions
of pounds so we've been very very
careful and it's taking time and we will
take our time to get to the right answer
but the simple fact is until there is an
agreement on the figure from both sides
we aren't going to move towards well no
no that isn't the case I mean what
they've used this phrase they invented
this phrase sufficient progress right
it's in as it were in their control what
it really is but one of the reasons they
did it was
because we said all right we'll do this
sequencing but don't imagine you'll have
a number or a formula at the end of it
we will get get towards that process but
you won't have a number or formula
before we move on to the next stage they
accepted that so the it's not to be
expected suddenly to come along and say
here's another five billion or whatever
you know but to move on to Phase two
minutes not within your gift is it it's
within theirs well it's it's both of
course but yeah the 27 will and will
make their decision whether or not to
move on that's right are you do you
concede in the same way that the chance
that has done that this uncertainty and
businesses are looking for details about
the transition periods your businesses
are looking for details as to the final
deal that this uncertainty is having an
effect on it has some of course it does
of course it doesn't mean no we're gonna
we've got a two-year negotiation going
on you know but the businesses were
talking about I mean I was a director of
a footsie 100 this is actually two of
them various times I know quite what
it's like you don't have absolute
certainty of business and if you're in
business you know that when you start
the negotiation you don't know exactly
how long the last or indeed what the
exact outcome will be you know we are
going and what we're doing in this
exercise is that trying to design this
to give the maximum so that's one of the
reasons that we're saying one of the
first things the first thing we're going
to set to resolve in phase two as soon
as it starts is the implementation
period or transition period yeah what
that will do is give businesses two
years to plan or there abouts when we
get to the end this other better make a
plan on the basis of certainty so that's
designed specifically to give certainty
but isn't it the case actually we weep
you mentioned there you know you never
know how long the negotiating process
will last but we we do don't wait we
have a date at which we will be coming
out of the European we know that we know
where it's not we have a deal as we know
to you and that we know the end stop we
know when we're aiming for which is the
sort of latter part of next year autumn
2018 both sides want to want to hit that
sort of target so we have a broad idea
but in terms of what the outcome will be
exactly in any business in any even
remotely complex business negotiation
even if you go buy a house you don't
know when you start where you end up the
carpets and curtains what the exact
price will be etc etc and it this this
is taking 40 years of law
forty years of relationship and turning
it into what we hope is an infinite
period of friendship you know so that's
a complex thing to do the most complex
negotiation probably in history and so
you know people will be unreasonable to
expect absolute certainty from day one
given all of that why then won't you
countenance any set of circumstances in
which article fifty could be paused to
increase the amount of time available
for the negotiations well you just said
you know business of looking for
certainty they want another uncertainty
extending the thing future into the
future also in order to pause it as we
answer but not pauses you know what do I
extend it by year let alone pause it I'm
not sure you can pause it we're even to
extend it by year take unanimity of all
the other 27 what can the price of that
would be you know when you when you
require unanimity from 27 countries I
can tell you if you very expensive I
thought I thought they weren't trying to
punish as I thought they wanted us to
have listened in in a European
negotiation in a European negotiation
very often you've my one country will
hold it to get something particularly
once if you say at 27 countries well
like another year thank you one of them
will put a price on it at least if not
27 if we do move on to stage two it
phase two and that is not yet certain
you've got around about 10 months to
work out as you say the most complicated
- trade deal in our nation's history the
European Union doesn't appear to think
it can be done so why do you well
because it will be well to two
overarching reasons number one we're
starting at the same place most trade
deals know if if we did have trade deal
with America we'd be looking at the
standards of the products we're selling
to each other words or stuff with the
European Union they're the same we have
exactly the same stance on day we leave
so you're actually controlling
divergence from the coverage so you've
got an instant a couple of years saved
over that the second thing is that what
we're looking for is actually very
simple at one level and that is we want
a no tariffs a tariff free deal which
then allows us to have a very simple
customs agreement those things make it
simpler make it easier to do quickly can
we just talk for it for a second about
the possibility of no deal and of course
you're not you're not working towards
that you're working towards a deal but
it it remains a possibility and I'd
submit perhaps more of a possibility
that there than ever before I mean if a
deal is not struck with a trap
interpersonal failures one or two things
firstly I mean you're right when there's
not worry meaningful secondly are what I
won't accept that it's more probable
than it's ever been before
you know the the moods are so we get the
closer we get to that December meeting
of the European connect so clearly it's
more you know we could have this
interview every three months the next
two years and the recycles in the time
you know people get more tense and less
tense that's how that's how negotiations
advance by pressure on each side but but
understand one of the things one of the
parts of my job third to a half of my
job in a way is planning for every
outcome and we have a huge planning
operation for every outcome and we will
be ready if that happens it's not what
we want because the trade deal that
we're talking about but it's not just
trade trade security Foreign Affairs
defense all those deals all of those
deals are much better than no deal but
let's just examine what could happen in
the event of an ordeal a brexit means
brexit if no deal means no deal the day
after we come out of the European Union
there could be knock-on effects to our
policing you have to be a member of the
European Union to be part of Europe all
at your Atem as well there could be real
significant consequences for our health
service aviation let's be clear about
that the day after we connect planes
might not fly well that's what I've
heard said but it's not the case look
let's just take one country I mean just
because you were 27 companies have got
an interest in this - not just as they
explain what would happen if suddenly
there was a disruption of flights
between Britain Spain you've got a huge
industry
tourist industry depend on it you've got
a huge property model I'm talking to the
rationale for adjusted the simple think
ality of a well with with great respect
the the the rationale is important the
incentive is important where we will be
will if we're at this point with No Deal
well no it's coming for a while and
we'll take measures to make sure that
there's what you're describing doesn't
happen but that's impossible
ten months which is which is why I've
talked about it
various times a bare-bones deal or
minimalist deal because we don't least
we don't want that either frankly but
don't don't assume that we haven't
thought through the endgame end
contingencies of this and we have there
will not be a circumstance
aircraft won't fly there will not be a
circumstance where we can't exchange
data with the European institutions
there will not be those sorts of those
sorts of failures that people are
fearing will make sure that them but
what of the border between either
Republic and Northern Ireland
I mean clearly there if there is no deal
that there are two options one there is
a hard border to Northern Ireland
remains and the customs union one of the
things we have to understand is that
we'd be talking about unique solutions
in order now well-being we're looking
for a unique solution in the event that
the that we have a deal but even today I
think mr. right in the last day or so
this variety was accepted that the
staying inside the customs union is not
a real option it wouldn't be a real
option for the large part community in
Northern Ireland and that's the first
interest we have so that all means a
hard border and no it doesn't know he
doesn't know I think I think we'll find
other ways around that I'm look at the
moment let me just let me just say this
to you the currently there are
differences in excise rates and and so
on north and south the border
you know they exist there now right
that's the first thing to understand the
second thing the most fundamental aspect
of the border the free movement of
people across that border is not
underpinned by the European Union
it's underpinned by the by the by the
common travel area for us that's been
there since 1923 and it will be there
probably in twenty one twenty three
we've learned today that the European
Union is actively planning for a future
a situation which Teresa may is not
Prime Minister have you given any
thought to that I think I would be very
surprised they'd really I know I know
it's in the papers I'd be very suppose
they really are like that the Prime
Minister will be here right through
brexit and to my retirement as it works
its really in Britain and she'll be on
my boss for that I'm quite certainly but
you can't you can't not concede the fact
that there is a chaotic quality to
government at the moment you've lost two
secretaries of state you've got the
foreign secretary potentially adding
years to the sentence of a British
national who's released they were trying
to secure okay well on the topic of mr.
Johnson is he unsaddle why would you
want to sack him is it he's good for a
sec
I mean look the thing to understand here
you know you've got you've got a sort of
a flurry at the moment I things
happening in politics but this happens
to all governments at some point or
another really understand well no no not
necessarily
I mean I suggest you have a look at
Churchill's government in the early
1940s before before he went on to great
success by the war you know or other
ones I know I served in your matrix
government for a long while and we had
flurries there to say the least but we
have been a hotend and Tony Blair's head
flurries and and and actually David
Cameron sat right so so all of them have
issues that come up and go that's the
nature of politics is one of the things
that makes it exciting of course but if
but it is the nature policy the trick
the trick in it all is to keep your eye
on what you're supposed to achieve in a
my task my job is I'm amorous enough to
think it's important and and I'm very
focused on that and not anything another
aspect that you have to deal with
there's a politician within politics is
satire you've been referred to by some
as they're the brexit build-up would you
make of that well I all my colleagues
and I've never heard it actually but the
welcome like all my colleagues were very
funny tell me I ought to listen it tell
me it's very funny they tell me is very
good and they tell me actually it's
quite kind so that's more than you can
normally ask for indeed David Davis many
thanks thank you and with that almost
time for us both to pack up and head for
home
but not before another candid moments
with one of politics great survivors but
you are you are you are you enjoying
yourself yeah yeah I mean the bits of
evasion irritating bits which great it
matters you know you can save yourself
when you work from three to twelve for
the more you overnight
actually it matters and yeah where do
you think that everything everything
just gets like will this smile ever
leave the Secretary of State's face it's
certainly difficult to imagine this is a
politician clearly reveling in the task
at hand but it's a task that's far from
complete